ja ich mache jetzt seit über 30 Jahren
ehrenamtlich Flüchtlingshilfe und
konnte somit auch die Entwicklung
verfolgen wie damals im ehemaligen
Jugoslawien der Krieg ausgebrochen ist
da war ja die Haltung der damaligen
Bundesregierung eine ganz andere da
wollte man gar keine Flüchtlinge
aufnehmen dann hat man sich für 10.000
bereit erklärt Schluss letztendlich
waren es 265.000 die gekommen sind aber
es war klar diese Menschen kommen weil
jetzt eben dort Krieg ist und man
versorgt sie und wenn der kriegt zu Ende
ist gehen Sie zurück und man hilft beim
Aufbau des Landes das ist auch so
passiert 65000 sind also hier geblieben
weil sie eben in Arbeit oder Ausbildung
waren
wie
2015/2016 die flüchtlingskrise losging
habe ich das schon mit großen
Bauchschmerzen gesehen weil
wir klar war wir haben weder die
Manpower noch haben wir die die
Voraussetzung diese Menschen adäquat zu
versorgen und die Frau Dr Merkel hat es
ja sehr schlau gemacht die hat ja immer
gesagt wir schaffen das sie hat aber nie
festgelegt was schaffen wir und wie
damals die Flüchtlinge so an den
Bahnhöfen begrüßt worden sind von von
einigen Bürgern wie Popstars also
wirklich die waren ja völlig euphorisch
und Kultur da wurden meine
Bauchschmerzen noch größer weil mir war
klar das sind nicht die Leute die
hinterher helfen diese Menschen hier
auch ankommen zu lassen zu integrieren
und
nachhaltig in die Mitte der Gesellschaft
zu holen und es ist völlig in die Hose
gegangen das muss man ganz klar sagen
letztes Jahr sind 44% aller Asylanträge
abgelehnt worden das ist einfach
folgedessen dass die Menschen hier
völlig unkontrolliertens Land kommen das
ist vorher überhaupt nicht geprüft wird
gibt es asylinder oder nicht
auch diese 44 Prozent die abgelehnt
wurden bleiben trotzdem hier mit einer
Duldung das heißt diese Menschen leben
in Gemeinschaftsunterkünften immer mit
ja sie könnten theoretisch jederzeit
abgeschoben werden was aber in der
Realität nicht passiert also es werden
im Schnitt so 15% nur wirklich auch dann
in die Heimatländer zurückgeschickt es
ist ein riesen Thema und wenn man
überlegt dass jetzt im Moment ja nicht
nur durch den Ukraine Krieg wieder sehr
viele Menschen gekommen sind
sondern auch so 30.000 Flüchtlinge jeden
Monat nach Deutschland kommen und die
wollen auch immer sehr gerne explizit
nach Deutschland das ist auch einfach so
dann ja bereitet mir das schlaflose
Nächte das kann ich schon so sagen jetzt
muss man dazu sagen Frau schneid sie
waren selbst auch Flüchtlingshelferin
haben sie immer noch ich bin's halt
mittlerweile Club 33 Jahren
ehrenamtliche Flüchtlingshelferin auch
heute noch als gestern erst wieder in
der Unterkunft und habe viele Menschen
nachhaltig integriert also eine
flüchtlingsfrau die 2015 aus Syrien
gekommen ist es heute meine
Kundenberaterin bei der Sparkasse wollte
ich noch mal an der Stelle sagen auch
das gibt es aber das ist nicht die Regel
und das müssen wir ganz klar sagen das
ist im Gegenteil die Ausnahme stellen
Sie uns einmal was sie in ihrem Ehrenamt
beobachten und wo sie für sich ganz
persönlich erkannt haben so können wir
das nicht machen so geht das nicht
weiter hier muss ich was ändern es muss
ich alles ändern also unsere ganze
Asylpolitik ist einfach eine Katastrophe
und ähm wir müssen anfangen zu
unterscheiden holen wir wirklich
Menschen aus Kriegsgebieten hierher die
alles recht haben wirklich auch hier zu
sein oder unterstützen wir weiterhin
Wirtschaftsflüchtlinge und ein ganz
großer Teil der Menschen die kommen sind
Wirtschaftsflüchtlinge und das ist ein
Problem
denn diese Menschen kommen hierher weil
einfach die Anreize die wir hier haben
sehr sehr hoch sind wir haben ja
wirklich noch sehr gut funktionierendes
Sozialsystem und das ist einfach ein
sehr hoher Anreiz und deswegen kommen
die Menschen auch ganz gezielt hierher
und wollen eben nicht in einem der
Länder bleiben durch die sie reisen das
ist einfach so
und man muss einfach glaube ich diesen
diesen Flüchtlings Tourismus der also
entstanden ist den müsste man eindämmen
das ist genauso wie ich habe ja viele
auch aus der Ukraine viele Familien die
ukrainische Menschen aufgenommen haben
die mich irgendwann total entsetzt
angerufen haben gesagt ist der Krieg
vorbei in der Ukraine und ich sag nein
warum ja die sind jetzt in Urlaub
gefahren die haben Bus gebucht die
fahren jetzt drei Wochen in die Ukraine
die machen da Urlaub und das sind
natürlich so Dinge sowieso dann den
Menschen ganz schlecht erklären kannst
ja die vorher alles dafür getan haben um
diesen Menschen eine gewisse Sicherheit
hier zu bieten ja und
ich weiß nicht warum wir diese
Flüchtlingspolitik betreiben
es ist wir haben so gut wie keine
wirklichen flüchtlingshelfer also es
lastet alles auf uns ehrenamtlichen und
auch die werden immer weniger und die
Menschen sind auf sich alleine gestellt
die Parallelgesellschaften werden immer
größer
die haben so Fahrt aufgenommen dass es
wirklich erschreckend ist
sie eine Erklärung dafür dass die
Politik diese Menschen im Stich lässt
auch sie werden in ihrer Arbeit
öffentlich Helferinnen
ich glaube schon dass Deutschland sehr
viel tut übrigens auch im sehr privaten
Bereich um gerade ukrainische
Flüchtlinge Kriegsflüchtlinge ja
natürlich klar also ich habe in der
letzten Sendung als ich hier war auch
die Frage gestellt wie da war das Haus
hier ein
migrationswissenschaftler ich habe den
als Wirtschaftswissenschaftler den
migrationswissenschaften die Frage
gestellt wie er ist erklärt dass das war
also
an dem Zeitpunkt gerade so dass paar
Tage später ich habe das Recherchieren
lassen allein aus Berlin 32 flixbusse
nach
Kiew gefahren sind also das ist das was
sie jetzt auch genau er hat es dann auch
erklärt warum die dahin fahren und
wieder zurück und so weiter die fahren
wieder her aber ich meine das ist sie
steht da schon voll dahinter dass diesen
Menschen geholfen wird
und dass die Kinder die da kommen
ordentliche Grundschule Ausbildung oder
Schulausbildung wahnsinnige
Anforderungen auch an unsere Lehrkräfte
sagenhaft was da abgefordert wird und
man schafft hier auch bei den
Jugendlichen und Kindern die aus der
Ukraine heute hier sind die dann wieder
zurückgehen auch ein Stück Deutschland
Verbundenheit das hat auch langfristige
positive Folgen in Deutschland
muss dort wo es zerstört ist auch wieder
aufgebaut werden das heißt ich gehe mal
davon aus dass die meisten davon auch
wieder zurückgehen
festlegen weil die Ukraine ist nur ein
Beispiel also wir haben ja viele
Flüchtlinge aus afghanist
natürlich
kommen weil wenn Wirklichkeit was
Algerien etc das sind ja Sachen die
begleiten mich seit über 30 Jahren die
Ukraine ist jetzt ein kleiner Teil und
das ist sicherlich schwer den Menschen
begreiflich zu machen wieso fahren die
in Kriegsgebiete das machen aber im
übrigen andere Flüchtlinge auch
das ist jetzt kein ukraine-problem aber
Fakt ist natürlich auch dass wir hier
wir haben unsere ärztliche Versorgung
steht vor dem absoluten Kollaps ja also
ich sage Ihnen was ich habe mir jetzt
ein Hautarzttermin gemacht den habe ich
jetzt im September 2025 das ist kein
Witz ja ich stehe bei meiner Hausärztin
da steht eine Frau weinend an der an der
Anmeldung und sagt ihr Hausarzt ist
jetzt geht jetzt zum eintresten 12 in
Ruhestand und sie findet keinen neuen
Hausarzt also wir haben bei uns in der
Stadt 12 Hausärzte und keine nimmt neue
Patienten auf weil alle am Limit sind ja
heute morgen habe ich gerade bevor ich
hierher gefahren bin erfahren dass eine
gute Bekannte von mir verstorben ist ja
einem Herzinfarkt weil sie vier Wochen
auf einen Kardiologen Termin gewartet
hat obwohl der Hausarzt sie schon als
Notfall angemeldet hat das ist die
Realität und ähm wir haben überhaupt
nicht mehr die Strukturen noch mehr
Menschen aufzunehmen wir haben weder die
Wohnungen noch haben wir die kinderbe
Plätze noch haben wir die ärztliche
Versorgung wir haben sie nicht ja und es
ist für mich unbegreiflich wenn ich sehe
dass 44% der Asylanträge abgelehnt
worden sind wenn ich sehe dass Experten
wie die flüchtlingskrise im Jahr 2015
begonnen hat haben die hochgerechnet wie
viel Sozialwohnungen müssen wir zur
Verfügung stellen um das zu stemmen und
diese Experten haben hochgerechnet dass
wir bis ins Jahr 2022 jedes Jahr 240.000
Sozialwohnungen hätten bauen müssen es
ist nicht passiert und ja aber gut dass
du das das Problem ist ja nicht nur die
wie geht man um mit Flüchtlingen sondern
das Problem ist dass es tatsächlich
keine
Einwanderungspolitik aus einem Guss gibt
eine katastrop brauchen wir
Arbeitskräfte völlig klar
ganz ehrlich also ich sage immer was wie
es damals geheißen hat jetzt kommen die
Fachkräfte ich bin auch Deutsch lernen
für geflüchtete da habe ich mich gefragt
okay Katja hast du jetzt nur die
Analphabeten abbekommen also ich habe
mit den angefangen des Alphabet zu
lernen und wie dann die ersten Zahlen
der Arbeitsagentur kamen die besagt
haben dass fast 80 Prozent der Menschen
weder eine Ausbildung noch ein
Schulabschluss haben da ist das die
Realität und wenn man jetzt sieht das
von 2015 die Leute die gekommen sind ja
70 Prozent habe ich heute noch habe ich
heute noch in den
Gemeinschaftsunterkünften sitzen mit
mangelnden Sprachkenntnissen leben von
Sozialhilfe und es hat also es ist eine
Katastrophe da ist nichts mit
Fachkräften zwei Seiten es gelingt uns
offensichtlich nicht tatsächlich hoch
motivierte und gut qualifizierte
Menschen nach Deutschland zu holen das
ist eine es gelingt uns aber nicht
qualifizierte Menschen hierher zu holen
und sobald jemand sagt genau gibt es
hier eine ganze Reihe von Organisationen
die alles dafür tun dass diese Person
bleibt so lange sie möchte und an beiden
Seiten hakt es ja es hat daran
tatsächlich die Leute Deutschland
attraktiv zu machen für die Leute die
wir wirklich brauchen und auf der
anderen Seite vielleicht nicht so
attraktiv zu machen für die Leute die
wir nicht brauchen und die aber auch
nicht im eigentlichen Sinne Schutz
Bedürfnis ist ja wie gesagt die Anreize
sind ja auch so hoch wie soll ich denn
einer Familie guck mal
Flüchtlingsfamilie zwei Kinder bekommen
an Mietzahlung Sozialleistungen brauchen
kein Kindergartenplatz zu bezahlen keine
Zusagen sind roundabout ungefähr 1800
Euro netto die sie zur Verfügung haben
mit Miete wie gesagt mit
Kindergartenplätze jetzt will ich stehen
für Mindestlohn den Papa Arbeiten
schicken und dann würde der heimkommen
und hätte noch 1400 da zeigt mir doch
ein Vogel der sagt wenn ich hier in
Deutschland gar nichts mache ich habe
1800 und wenn ich jetzt 40 Stunden die
Woche arbeiten gehe ich komme mit 1400
nach Hause nein das ist ein Problem ist
auch in Bayern
seit dieser Woche können Sie das doch
heute nach Hause seit 650 Einwohner ist
eine große Geschichte im Bayerischen
Rundfunk gewesen ist in der Nähe von
Schrobenhausen dieses Dorf und dort gibt
es schlägt der Bürgermeister dieser
Alarm 50 geflüchtete Menschen sind dort
und seitdem kann dieses Dorf steht für
wahnsinnig vielen Problemen und fühlt
sich alleine gelassen der Bürgermeister
nannte Beispiele das ist eine
Trauerfeier sie kennen das kennen Sie
pointenhaus sie haben diese Geschichte
gehört
ich kenne dieses einzeldorf Problem
[Gelächter]
im Berchtesgadener Land und Siegfried
Wald im Landkreis Traunstein ja die
berichten mir beinahe täglich über die
Probleme die wir haben jetzt am letzten
Wochenende habe ich wieder mit beiden
gesprochen die sagen wir schaffen es
also jede Woche werden pro Landkreis 50
Flüchtlinge einfach zugewiesen einfach
zu wie gesagt
das geht so nicht mehr weiter aber die
Regierung von Oberbayern sagt
ihr kriegt die auf dem Hof gestellt jede
Woche 50 das sind auch alle
familientyp-typen Zusammensetzungen
dabei irgendwie müsst ihr brauchen bis
jetzt sagen die haben das gerade noch
geschafft ohne die Beschlagnahmung und
Nutzung von schulternhallen aber
irgendwann ist der Punkt überschritten
und dann sie haben völlig richtig gesagt
oder waren sie wir Angela Merkel gesagt
wir schaffen
gesagt
in der Bevölkerung wenn dann nicht mehr
genutzt werden sogar höhere Zahlen nur
sprechen wir weniger drüber das ist das
ist der Punkt und berichten darüber
natürlich auch ein Teil des Ganzen
Problems dass wir Probleme so lange
unter Teppich kehren bis wieder
irgendjemand sie aussieht höchste Frage
die mir bringen gestellt wird wenn neue
Flüchtlinge kommen ist tatsächlich wann
bekomme ich denn Haus und ich habe das
irgendwann angefangen zu hinterfragen
und das ist tatsächlich die Verdiener
die Schleuser sind ja nach wie vor aktiv
die erzählen den Leuten die darüber du
kriegst jeden Monat 1000 Euro du kriegst
ein Haus die wollen dich die warten auf
Dich und ich habe also schon so oft
appelliert auch an die Regierung endlich
Informationspolitik zu betreiben ja und
den Leuten wissen Sie diese diese
Flüchtlinge die sind ja die sind ja auch
Opfer das darf man nicht vergessen die
bekommen in ihren Herkunftsländern die
tollsten Sachen von Deutschland erzählt
die Schlepper die die gehen teilweise
her die die Mütter verkaufen ihren
Familien Schmuck damit die Schlepper
bezahlt werden können nach wie vor ja da
hat sich überhaupt nichts dran geändert
und dann kommen die hierher und finden
sich plötzlich in irgendeine
Gemeinschaftsunterkunft wieder die
schämen sich zu Tode und ich habe immer
gesagt warum transportieren die diese
Informationen nicht in ihr Herkunftsland
damit eben nicht noch mehr nachkommt die
schämen sich und dann gehen die her wenn
die im Monats anfangen hier ihr Geld
bekommen ihre Sozialhilfe hat vier und
dann legen die das meinen Haufen 345
Leute und fotografieren das sind ja in
den Herkunftsländer ist das ja unfassbar
viel Geld und das sind die Bilder die
die in ihre Herkunftsländer schicken
damit die Familien beruhigt sind ja und
weil sie sich schämen ihn die Realität
zu sagen und ich habe schon so oft an
die Regierung appelliert und habe gesagt
bitte bitte betreibt eine transparente
Informationspolitik in den
Herkunftsländern damit die Leute nicht
mehr auf diese Schlepper reinfallen und
wissen was sie hier erwartet das ist zum
Beispiel eine ganz konkrete Forderung
eine transparente Informationspolitik
auch aus den Herkunftsländer wir haben
jetzt viele Beispiele hier gehört ihre
Regierung ich habe öfter schon in der
Sendung gesagt sie sitzt in ihrem Partei
sitzt in der Regierung das entgegen sie
in der Tat wir sitzen seit
2021 in der Regierung hier in
im Bund und ich will das noch mal
sortieren das Lagebild weil wir haben
natürlich die Situation dass wir eine
Einwanderungspolitik zielgerichtet
gesteuert machen müssen dafür brauchen
wir aber eine gute
Einwanderungspolitik in der Frage der
Integrationspolitik in der Frage sie
haben das so schön vorhin auch noch mal
rechtlich dargestellt ne Schutz suchen
Asyl wer ist ähm Asyl Empfänger ist
alles im Gesetz geregelt aber alles was
im Gesetz geregelt ist heißt eben auch
dass jemanden ordentliches Asylverfahren
durchläuft und wenn das Gesetz zu der
Auffassung kommt dass dieser Status
nicht vorhanden ist dann heißt es eben
auch dass für ein funktionierenden
Rechtsstaat es dann heißen muss dass wir
an den Stellen und wir haben sie gerade
in Berlin mit der Frage auch
zurückzuführen der Moldavia dann
entsprechend die Rückführung nachdem ein
ordnungsgemäßes
Rechtsverfahren durchlaufen wurde auch
vollzogen wird
dass wir das einmal sortieren da wo wir
regeln Regelwerk haben anwenden
die nicht sicheren Herkunft
zweitens dass wir die Frage beantworten
wie können wir Einwanderung in den
Arbeitsmarkt besser organisieren das
muss dringend angegangen werden mein
Eindruck ist dass die Bundesregierung an
dieser Frage ernsthaft auch arbeitet
dass das besser wird mit klarem Regeln
und mit klaren
Prioritäten hier auch und das andere
sind die die Krisenherde die wir in äh
auf der Welt haben wo ich glaube hier
Konsens ist und sie haben es ja gerade
auch noch mal gesagt mit Blick auf die
jüngste Krise mit dem Angriffskrieg auf
die Ukraine hier entsprechend Asyl zu
gewähren
zu ermöglichen und ich kenne das hier
aus der Stadt Berlin hier sind 360.000
Ukrainerinnen an Ukraine angekommen
360.000
davon sind 100.000 in der Stadt
geblieben und nach meinem Kenntnisstand
sind davon etwa 70 bis 80.000 privat
untergekommen der Rest in staatlichen
Einrichtung des zeigt wie groß und auch
wie dankbar wir sein können auch für die
Arbeit die sie im übrigen leisten
dass wir Integration und
Flüchtlingshilfe hier machen und das
kann nur mittel und langfristig gelingen
wenn der Staat da wo er Gesetze hat sie
auch anwendet und tatsächlich damit den
Rechtsrahmen den er hat auch ausschöpft
nur dann kann das gelingen was sie auch
beschrieben haben und da müssen wir
müssen wir in der Tat besser werden da
muss man sogar ran das ist ein Thema wir
haben uns hier gerade im Dezember die
Frage auf der wohl da wir präsentiert es
müssen einfach gucken Sie mal ich
begleite Asylverfahren
15 Jahre
15 Jahre wo Menschen in
Gemeinschaftsunterkünften sitzen die
nicht privat ziehen dürfen weil sie
könnten
Situation abgeschoben werden könnten das
heißt die dürfen kein Eigentum besitzen
das sind Kinder die sind in die sind in
anderthalb Zimmern mit Gemeinschaftsklo
und Abschiebungen und Kriminalität
durcheinander
gehen Supervision also wenn ich einfach
merke da sind ja Schicksale dabei die
auch für mich sehr belasten sind weil
natürlich wenn du dich kümmerst über
viele Jahre da entstehen ja auch enge
Bindungen ja und ich konzentriere mich
ja tatsächlich auf die Menschen die
wollen ja also diese sag mal wirklich 10
bis 15% haben wir ja die wirklich wollen
so und auf die konzentriere ich mich und
natürlich hast du deine Bindung zu den
Menschen und wenn ich sehe das 15 Jahre
ein Kind niemanden aus dem aus dem
Kindergarten oder der Schule zu sich
nach Hause einlädt nie ein
Kindergeburtstag feiern weil es einfach
so schön für diese ärmlichen Verhältnis
ein bisschen runtergekommenen
Flüchtlingsunterkünfte und das muss man
auch mal sagen die meisten haben ja
immer das Bild von wir haben hier neue
tolle Flüchtlingsunterkünfte gebaut das
ist auch nicht richtig also es gibt
Flüchtlingsunterkünfte da würde ich
nicht mal meinen Hund drin unterbringen
geschweige denn irgendein Mensch sie
sprechen einen Punkt dieses Verfahren da
muss man ganz kurz und da muss man auch
ganz klar sagen die Vermieter diese
Unterkünfte die verdienen sich dumm und
blöd die verdienen mit so einem alten
abbruchreifenhaus und der Umständen
20.000 € im Monat diese vom Kreis
bezahlt bekommen weil sie nämlich pro
Person Geld bekommen und da werden
einfach Unmengen an Leute dort
untergebracht und kein Mensch
kontrolliert ist das ist auch eine
Realität und wenn Sie einen
Asylverfahren haben was wirklich über 15
Jahre sich zieht ja und sie sehen so ein
Mädchen ich meine es heute sie ist
verheiratet sie hat ist großen Augen
Außenhandelskauffrau sie erbaut gerade
ein Haus also angekommen diese Familie
hier dann stellst du dir schon die Frage
was passiert hier und es ist auch eine
Forderungen unsere Politik wo ich ganz
klar sage
kein Asylverfahren darf länger dauern
wie sechs Monate wenn ich einen Menschen
fünf sechs Jahre hier geduldet habe den
kann ich doch gar nicht mehr
zurückschicken das geht doch gar nicht
der hat doch den Anschluss schon längst
Pause eine Lösung ja Beschleunigung der
Verfahren das heißt aber auch sechs
Monate maximal auszustatten das da
scheint mir eines der Probleme zu sein
dass ich da die da die Verfahren
man hat sogar Richter aus dem Ruhe
360.000
diese diese langen Verfahren mit einer
mit Ketten Duldungen und so wo das
letztendlich zugeführt hat unklare ähm
unklarer Status sehen wir hier an den
klaren unter anderem in Berlin das sind
alles Leute die hätten auch ein anderes
Schicksal haben können da hat auch
natürlich Bürokratie dass ihre dazu
getan also Beschleunigung von Verfahren
die Integration auch ernst zu nehmen ja
damit uns damit wir uns nicht dran
gewöhnen dass sowas wie
öfter passiert da heißt es aber auch
noch mal in Behörden zu investieren auch
in die Polizei zu investieren das wäre
auch noch mal eine Maßnahme und
ansonsten ich unterstütze das auch
Informationspolitik anders kann das
nicht sein dass sich nicht jeder auf den
Weg macht nur weil ihm irgendein
Schlepper oder verwandter irgendwas
erzählt hat vielleicht sogar sein Leben
dabei verliert es ist ja auch gefährlich
diese Fluchtroute also das da Klarheit
tatsächlich zu schaffen und dann haben
wir den die große Baustelle
Rückführungen ja woran scheitern
Rückführungen natürlich einerseits daran
dass Leuten auch von Hilfsorganisationen
die ganzen Tricks verraten werden wie
man dem entgehen kann der gibt es ja
viele aber natürlich auch die ähm
Klassifizierung von Staaten als unsicher
also wir haben Krisenherde ohne Ende auf
der Welt wir werden nicht alle
Krisenherde als unsichere
staatenklassifizieren können das würde
nämlich bedeuten nehmen alle Leute auf
die in irgendeiner Weise in schlechteren
Lebensverhältnissen sind das ist ja eine
schlechterdings nicht möglich und
Rückführungsabkommen mit bestimmten
Ländern da muss man glaube ich auch noch
mal ein bisschen nachlegen dass Länder
bereit sind ihre Leute wieder
zurückzunehmen die sie exportieren ja
meine wir haben ja auch zum Teil ein
regelrechten staatlichen Export von
Menschen
starten die damit rechnen dass sie von
den Zahlungen derjenigen die ins Ausland
gegangen sind das davon die Wirtschaft
wohnt in vielen Ländern ist das ja
wirklich eine Größe zahlreiche
Vorschläge die Herr Chaya auch mitnimmt
auch offene Worte Probleme benennen
genau das wollen wir hier in dieser
Sendung und damit machen wir auch gleich
weiter kurze Pause bei viertel nach acht
wir freuen uns wenn Sie bei uns bleiben